[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild nachts um 3:30 Uhr auf einmal ein
übelstes dauerklingeln als hält jemand
den Finger die ganze Zeit auf den
Klingelknopf der Fall den wir euch heute
erzählen der macht mich persönlich
sprachlos es geht um Sophie n eine 23
Jahre alte lebenslustige Frau mit vielen
Träumen und Zielen zwei Jahre lang wird
sie gestockt am Ende steht ein
bestialischer Mord ein Fall der Anfang
2020 ganz Deutschland schockiert ich bin
Tony Haier und ich bin Mirko Kasimir
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen Fall hier bei Tatort
Deutschland Tony ich bin da ganz beide
denn dieser Fall ist wirklich äußerst
verstörend und das sehen nicht nur wir
so aber gehen wir erstmal zurück ins
Jahr
2020 zu diesem Zeitpunkt soll für Sophie
eigentlich ein neuer Lebensabschnitt
beginnen die junge Flugbegleiterin plant
nach Wien umzuziehen im Januar 2020
brechen die letzten Wochen für die
23-Jährige in ihrer WG in Hannover an R
Koffer sind gepackt sophie ist startklar
für die neue Stadt und den neuen
Arbeitgeber denn nach der Pleite von
Thomas will sie für Austrian Airlines
arbeiten schon als Kind war Sophie vom
Fliegen fasziniert und wollte unbedingt
Flugbegleiterin werden als junge Frau
ist dieser Traum in Erfüllung gegangen
wie happy sie mit ihrem Job ist das
sieht man auf Fotos Sophie strahlend in
Uniform auf einem Videoausschnitt
moderiert sie gut gelaunt eine
boardansage überhaupt die Fotos die
hätte auch wirklich Model werden können
muss ich sagen ganz glatte Gesichtszüge
strahlendes Lächeln volle Lippen
kräftiges blondes Haar eine wirklich
hübsche schöne junge Frau Fotos und
Videos spielen bei diesem Fall eine ganz
besondere Rolle denn auf sopies
Schnappschüsse und selfies hat auch ihr
Stalker Zugriff immer wenn Sophie ihr
Smartphone benutzt ist er mit dabei er
schaut sich Ihre Fotos an weiß wann sie
ihre Familie besucht weiß was sie mit
ihren Freundinnen austauscht er weiß
quasi alles über Sie Sophie weiß von all
dem nichts sie hat keine Ahnung dass Ihr
Handy überwacht wird und im Sommer 2018
da beginnt ja Albtraum es erscheinen
Fake Accounts im Netz die so viel
diffamieren und verängstigen sollen und
das ist noch nicht alles sie erhält bis
zu 164 Anrufe an einem einzigen Tag von
unbekannter Nummer für Sophie stellt
sich eine Frage immer und immer wieder
wer tut mir das an und warum seit 2007
gibt es in Deutschland im
Strafgesetzbuch den Paragraphen
238 er stellt unter Strafe einer anderen
Person nachzustellen doch was nützt das
wenn man nicht weiß wer einen stalkt wir
sind jetzt im Jahr 2017 in Dessau hier
ist Sophie groß geworden bevor sie als
Flugbegleiterin in Hannover durchstartet
absolviert Sophie eine Ausbildung zur
Tourismus und
Eventmanagerin neben ihrer Ausbildung
jobt sie als Aushilfe in einer H&M fili
im Rathaus Center Dessau einer ihrer
Kollegen in der Filiale ist Patrick S 32
Jahre alt Student der
Wirtschaftsmathematik die beiden
verstehen sich gehen ab und zu gemeinsam
was essen für Sophie ist es nur ein
Kollege jetzt Ende 2017 passiert etwas
Unglaubliches etwas Unerhörtes Patrick
verschafft sich Zugang zu Sophies Handy
ihre Pinnummer hat er durch
Beobachtungen abgegriffen er installiert
eine spionagea auf Ihrem
Smartphone das ist so gruselig wenn ich
mir das vorstelle da wird unbemerkt auf
deinem Handy eine Spionage Software
installiert und dein Handy überwacht
laut einer Studie des softwareanbieters
kasperskii führt Deutschland in dem
Bereich eine traurige Statistik an wir
sind das Land in Europa in dem
stalkerware am häufigsten eingesetzt
wurde 2018 tauscht Sophie Dessau gegen
das sonnige Barcelona ein hier macht sie
im Rahmen ihrer Ausbildung ein Praktikum
im April 2018 schaut Patrick für ein
paar Tage vorbei Sophie zeigt ihm die
Stadt so unter Kollegen Freunden wie sie
denkt doch Patrick ist mit anderen
Erwartungen in die Metropole am
Mittelmeer geflogen er erhofft sich mehr
will bei ihr übernachten am 28 april
2018 schickt sie an ihre Freundin
folgende Sprachnachricht
ich wollte dir eigentlich noch erzählen
dass ich mich gestern mega unwohl
gefühlt habe patrick ist ja immer schon
auf Arbeit auch so ein bisschen touchy
gewesen er hat immer mal so seinen Arm
um mich gelegt und jetzt wurde es halt
irgendwie immer mehr und er ist so nah
gekommen du weißt doch dass ich das
einfach null leiden kann wenn man mich
die ganze Zeit
antoucht im Juli fliegt er noch ein
weiteres Mal zu ihr nach Barcelona
diesmal wird sopie sehr deutlich sie
sagt ihm klar dass sie das nicht will
dass sie berührt als sie ihn zurückweist
reagiert er wütend und uneinsichtig und
reiß daraufhin ab Sophie bricht
endgültig den Kontakt zu ihm ab patrick
ist für sie von nun an
Vergangenheit für Patrick sieht das
allerdings anders aus er ist von Sophie
besessen die erhoffte Beziehung die hat
nicht geklappt da beschließt er zu
anderen Mitteln zu greifen patrick ist
in Sophies Leben anonym die ganze Zeit
präsent nach dem Kontaktabbruch beginnt
für Sophie ein wahres Stalking Martyrium
es tauchen zahlreiche Profile im
Internet von ihr auf montierte Pornos
gefälschte Nacktbilder ihr Handy
klingelt ständig und nachts klingelt es
an der Wohnungstür er lässt sie wissen
dass er ständig in Ihrer Nähe ist er
stört sogar ihre Beziehungen bzw er
zerstört Sie Sophie weiß nicht wer sie
stockt aber ihr reicht es jetzt sie
erstattet Anzeige gegen Unbekannt der
Fall landet irgendwann beim LKA
Cybercrime doch niemand kann ja helfen
die IP-Adressen können nicht ermittelt
werden sie verlaufen ins Ausland patrick
hat inzwischen auch GPS Tracker an Ihrem
Auto und dem Auto ihrer Mutter
angebracht er weiß zu jeder Zeit wo
Sophie gerade ist Ende 2018 zieht sie
dann beruflich nach
Hannover Patrick der mit seinen
inzwischen 33 Jahren noch bei seinen
Eltern in Dessau lebt lauert regelmäßig
vor ihrer Wohnung in Hannover er
versteckt sich wenn Sophie bei ihrer
Mutter in desessau ist klingelt er auch
dort nachts an der Tür an einem Tag
schickte er ihr anonym ein Handyfoto vom
Zug mit dem Sie beruflich nach Frankfurt
fährt dann eine Aufnahme ihres
Hotelzimmers er versucht mit allen
Mitteln der Jungfrau zu schaden sie zu
ängstigen zu
kontrollieren doch irgendwann reicht ihm
das nicht mehr aus am 20 November 2019
kauft er ein Klappmesser und gegen Ende
2019 beschließt Patrick S aus Rache zu
töten die Ermittler werden später sagen
die Tat sei minuziös geplant gewesen für
Sophie bricht im Januar 2020 das letzte
Wochenende in Hannover an mit ihren
Freundinnen feiert sie fröhlich und
ausgelassen ihren Abschied nichts
natürlich am Ende des Wochenendes es ist
Sonntag der 10 Januar da bricht Patrick
s abends über die balkonttür in ihre
Erdgeschosswohnung ein im Prozess sagt
der Richter sie sind eingestiegen in
schwarzer kampfmontour mit Handschuhen
Sturmhaube und Schutzbrille sie hatten
Pfefferspray elektroschockeril
Glasschneider Klappmesser und
Handfesseln dabei die Fesseln waren
sogar zu schlingen vorbereitet das ist
Polizeitaktik um jemanden schneller über
Winden zu können sie sind extrem
zielgerichtet
vorgegangen und ich muss noch mal
betonen es ist Sonntag abend Patrick s
wird nun über 20 Stunden warten bis er
zur Tat schreitet er versteckt sich
unter dem Bett von sopies Mitbewohnerin
die an diesem Wochenende nicht zu Hause
ist am Montagabend fast 24 Stunden nach
dem Einbruch krieeg er unter dem Bett
hervor und überfällt sopie im Badezimmer
er überrascht sie sie gerade auf
Toilette ist mit mehreren Schlägen einem
Elektroschocker und Pfefferspray setzt
er sie außer Gefecht dabei zertrümmert
er Sophies Nasenknorpel vollständig
Sophie schreit kämpft um ihr Leben doch
Patrick s hält ihr den Mund zu versperrt
ihr den Weg sie liegt bereits hilflos am
Boden als er ihr eine 9 cm lange Klinge
in den Hals stößt Sophies Halsschlagader
wird durchtrennt sie hat keine Chance
mehr sie verblutet schnell
Patrick s fährt dann zurück nach Dessau
zu seinen Eltern einen Tag später stellt
er sich der Polizei mit den Worten er
habe in Hannover eine Frau getötet zu
der er ein komisches Verhältnis hatte
mehr als diesen einen Satz wird es von
ihm zu seiner Tat nicht
geben der Prozess zieht sich über
Monate in 25 Verhandlungstagen hat
Patrick s nichts gesagt der Richter
appelliert immer wieder an ihn zu reden
wei darau hin wie wichtig seine Aussage
für das Verfahren sei die Hoffnung dass
Patrick s sich doch noch äußert die
zerschlägt sich viele Fragen bleiben
unbeantwortet der Richter wendet sich
mit folgenden Worten an
Patrick es ist ziemlich verstörend ihr
Verhalten ist
verstörend es hat anderthalb Jahre
gedauert bis sie zur Tat geschritten
sind sie haben mit Absicht getötet sind
heimtürkisch vorgegangen und aus
niedrigen Beweggründen als Rache dafür
dass sie sie zurückgewiesen hat ihr Ziel
war es eine Beziehung einzugehen
verliebt sein und gleichzeitig
manipulativ aktiv sein aus der
Privatsphäre etwas abgreifen
Abfischen laut Ansicht des Richters
steckt hinter der Fassade des netten
freundlichen Chaos ein übergriffiger
grenzenverletzender und selbstbezogener
Mann das sieht auch die Staatsanwältin
so sie sagt er kam mit der Zurückweisung
einfach nicht klar machte sopie deshalb
das Leben zur Hölle und wollte sie nur
noch schädigen ihre Einschätzung
Patricks eigene Kränkung besaß einen
höheren Stellenwert als das Leben seines
Opfers es gibt aber eine Person mit der
Patrick s ausführliche Gespräche führt
und das ist der Gutachter der Psychiater
ihm erzählt er dass er um jeden Preis
wissen wollte warum sich sopie in
Barcelona so abweisend Verhalten habe
Patrick erwähnt dabei auch Situationen
in denen er sich sicher gewesen sei sie
hätte auch Interesse an ihm gut ein Jahr
nach dem Mord fällt das Urteil gegen ihn
vor Ort war damals bildreporterin
Christine Wall Patrick S wurde wegen
Mordes an der 23-Jährigen vor dem
Landgericht Hannover schuldig gesprochen
das Urteil des Richters lebenslange Haft
außerdem wurde die besondere Schwere der
Schuld festgestellt während der
Begründung weinte und zitterte der Täter
dass Sophie sich am Tag noch gegen ihn
gewährt hätte sei Grund dafür gewesen
dass sich Patrick s am nächsten Tag der
Polizei stellte so der Richter in seiner
Urteilsbegründung besondere schwre der
Schuld das heißt dass somit keine
vorzeitige Haftentlassung nach 15 Jahren
möglich ist Patrick s wird mindestens 25
Jahre im Gefängnis verbringen sopies
Mutter ist bei der Verlesung der
Anklageschrift dabei hört alle Details
mit an auf welch entsetz bestialische
Weise der Täter ihre Tochter getötet hat
ist das Urteil ein Trost das sagt der
Anwalt Marco bernewetz dazu was das
Ergebnis dieses strafrechtlichen
Verfahrens betrifft hat das natürlich
eine gewisse
Genugtuungsfunktion für die Mutter der
Getöteten dass der Angeklagte also hier
diesen Prozess nicht ausweichen konnte
und letztlich völlig zutreffend wegen
Mordes seiner lebenslangen
Freiheitsstrafe unter Feststellung der
besonderen Schwere der Schuld verurteilt
wurde für Sophies Mutter war ihre
Tochter ihr Lebensinhalt die beiden
hatten ein sehr enges Verhältnis mit dem
Tod von Sophie schwindet ihre
Lebenskraft Patricks Anwälte lieggen
Revision gegen das Urteil ein erst im
Oktober
2021 ist das Urteil endlich
rechtskräftig der Bundesgerichtshof hat
die Revision verworfen ja und jetzt
stell dir mal vor MKO dieser Typ der hat
sie bis in den Tod hinein gestockt zu
ihrer Beerdigung in Dessau da ließ er
Blumen schicken ja da kann man nur noch
mal sagen unser heutiger Fall ist
wirklich sehr verstörend und er zeigt
was für ein schwieriger Paragraph der
Paragraph 238 ist denn die Bringschuld
des Opfers also dass das Opfer Beweise
für das Stalking liefern muss die ist
natürlich alles andere als leicht wie im
genau dieser Fall der Mordfall Sophie
zeigt
unseren heutigen Fall den haben wir
unter anderem mit Artikeln und Videos
und Podcasts von Stern RTL Spiegel dem
NDR und bildde recherchiert Skript
Ariane Werner Schnitt und Aufnahme Tony
haer Postproduktion durch schwarz audio
berlin B danken euch dass ihr mit dabei
wart und freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder einschaltet alle
weiteren Infos zur heutigen Ausgabe
findet ihr in den showotes und damit bis
zum nächsten mal euer Mirko und eure
Tony
dir hat diese Folge von tout Deutschland
gefallen du bekommst von True Crime
einfach nicht genug dann hör jetzt in
unsere weiteren Folgen rein hier warten
mehr als 200 spannende Fälle auf dich
wie das Verschwinden von Rebecca Reusch
der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder die
Entführung von ursela Herrmann wir hören
uns bei Tat Deutschland